louis elisondo is a former u.s army
counterintelligence special agent who's
gained notoriety now for being the
director of the now defunct atip program
which was a program initiated by the
defense intelligence agency in order to
study unidentified aerial phenomenon
also known as ufos for those new to this
channel my name is kurt jaimungle
i'm a filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics
dedicated to the explication of what are
called theories of
everything from a theoretical physics
perspective clearly but also
exploring the potential connection
consciousness has to the fundamental
laws of nature
if those fundamental laws exist at all
the ufo phenomenon may seem tangential
but if you watch the podcast with kevin
knuth linked below you'll see that there
seems to be an intimate connection
between some of the deep mysteries of
the universe
and this phenomenon thus i'm interested
and i don't view this enigma with a
stigma
i'm not averse to it like much of the
scientific community is lou
has revealed more in this podcast than
in almost any other interview
and that's due to the exquisite
questions provided to me by you
as this was an ask me anything in fact
it was a live ama
so lou and i both thank you for that
each podcast on this channel
is punctiliously time stamped just look
at the description and you can navigate
to whichever question you'd like to
directly there are a couple sponsors of
today's podcast
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations
planning to avoid stockouts reduce
returns and inventory write-downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by a bright individual by the
name of amjad hussein who's been a huge
supporter of this podcast from its early
days
in fact amjad contributed some questions
to today's ama
and you can visit algo by going to
algo.com
algo the second sponsor is brilliant
brilliant illuminates the soul of math
science and engineering through
bite-sized interactive learning
experiences
brilliance courses explore the laws that
shape our world
elevating math and science from
something to be feared to a delightful
experience of guided discovery
more on them later if you'd like to see
more conversations like this then please
do consider
visiting patreon.com and contributing
whatever you can
each dollar helps tremendously there's
also a crypto and a paypal account which
has been opened up
recently in case donations there are
more in line with what you'd like to use
in a couple weeks i'm speaking to chris
langan who's famous for having the
highest recorded iq
in america on his cognitive theoretic
model of the universe which is a theory
of everything tomorrow i'm also speaking
to jeremy corbell
there's plenty more to be announced and
again if you'd like to support this
podcast if you'd like it to stay at a
technical level which requires plenty of
preparation then please do consider
becoming a patron
or donating in some other way shape or
form
thank you so much and enjoy so first i'm
going to get to a question that i had
which is
is there a correlation between any of
the characteristics of these uaps ufos
and some other characteristic for
example let's say that the
tic-tac-shaped ones are more violent
or the pyramidal shaped ones are faster
is there a classification of them and do
they have some other
characteristic associated with them so
the the the
characterizations that we have we have
seen today
really is a result uh of size believe it
or not
so and this is by no means comprehensive
but what we tend to see are the
the smaller vehicles tend to be uh think
of a sports car
are your are your uh saucer shaped
vehicles
whereas the larger vehicles let's say a
school bus
size is that of a of a cylindrical
object or roughly that of a tic tac or
even sometimes
described as a telephone pole and then
in shape so cylindrical and then the the
tend to be
the large ones really large ones tend to
be uh
not always but almost exclusively either
triangular shape
or boomerang shape now there are some
some
some anecdotal uh if you will
reports of of large saucers as well and
some shapes looking like a dumbbell
but the three primary categories tend to
be uh that we saw in it were
disc shape and then you have uh the
longer cylindrical shape and then
finally a large
large triangular shaped vehicle the
triangle vehicles are often described
as flying uh very close to the ground
and very very very quiet
silent and seem to kind of lumber if you
will
uh from place to place very slow
uh almost like you would imagine a large
durable perhaps
just kind of floating there silently
the the apex of those triangles are
often described with lights
of some sort or emitting some sort of of
radiation in the
in the visible light spectrum which uh
to a lot of the the if you will uh
people reported this information to
include first responders
um we'll often see the lights changing
color and
uh maybe maybe a result of some sort of
doppler shift that's occurring red blue
doppler ship
um but uh that's in essence the
the three primary shapes that that we we
have had reported
and are these shapes associated with any
other characteristics
for example violence or non-violence or
the shutting down of nuclear missiles
yeah kurt that's a great question you
know
so there's a difference between when we
say something's a potential threat
and and hostile intent and i think
people have confused the term
potential threat when you say potential
threat you know
as a physicist um there's a lot of
things in nature
that are potential threats but don't
need to harm you right it's just
it's for example i've often said if i go
to an airport
and i get on a 737 there's no real
threat there
but if i were to jump off and run along
the runway the tarmac
and i i happened to get too close to one
of these jet engines as it's you know
going down the runway chances are
there's going to be some sort of
biological consequence there's there's
an environmental threat
i'm probably going to lose some hearing
i'm probably going to get burned by the
jet exhaust
it's not necessarily an intended
consequence of the jet engine to harm me
and so anytime you're dealing with with
physics
and i think this topic of uap certainly
nests well within the
the realm of physics there's always
potential threat
um and that's just the way it it works
if you ever go to the cern
the large hadron collider uh you're
talking about
a a massive machine the world's largest
machine in fact ever built
um and it's it's hurtling some of the
smallest particles around nearly the
speed of light and if you look at the
shielding
that is around the the accelerator
it's massive uh you would think for
something so so
tiny and infinitesimally small uh why do
you need such a big machine well it
turns out that
you know there's there's potential
consequences when you're taking a
particle of matter and you're
accelerating it to the speed of light
almost the speed of light correct me uh
correction um so
uh it's i think it's it's
i think we need to be careful when we
when we go down that rabbit hole and say
something
is is you know uh threat versus hostile
intent you said
uh is there any any signs that these
things
are displaying some sort of you know
over hostility towards us or violence i
think you said
um you know we in in atib didn't see any
over
signs of as you say violence um but
you know there are individuals who have
reported that they've had
um contact and whatever that contact is
it's not always been pleasant according
to some of the eyewitnesses now
the question is have those eyewitnesses
really had a
close and personal interaction with this
or is it some sort of psychological
manifestation
uh that is occurring uh
we we simply don't know um for that
reason we were very careful
not to to stipulate any type of
intent behind these things and we
focused the only two things we really
focused on in atep was
what is it and how does it work uh we we
were nowhere
near getting to the point where we
understood its intentions or who was
behind the wheel or
the origins of these things it was
simply just as you can appreciate a
scientific approach
what is it and how does it work and if
we could answer those questions
maybe we'd have a better chance of
answering some of the other ones
you also mentioned that the june report
may be a whole lot a
quotation a whole lot of nothing now why
do you say that and why do you think
that is
and have you been briefed as to what's
going to come out in the news report
yeah i mean let me let me turn that
question right back around kurt and ask
you a question you know if i were to
write a 74-page
uh dissertation about a black hole um
today i probably it'd probably be a lot
more comprehensive than if i were to
write a 74-page dissertation about a
black hole back in 1965
because at the time these were
theoretical objects that we weren't even
sure if
existed some scientists believe that
they couldn't exist that these were just
some sort of
anomaly within einstein's calculations
so
we we don't have a really good firm
understanding of these things
and so you know what what are we going
to provide to congress well
we know that they're not u.s technology
okay that's that's that's
that's a pretty big big step forward but
other than that
you know we're still at the point where
we don't know if these things are some
sort of foreign adversarial technology
which it looks like they're probably not
or there's something else um so you know
there's not a whole lot you can say
about that you can say look there were
you know 170 some incidents of these
incidents
uh they performed in this way these were
the organizations involved these were
the people involved
this is the radar this is the video
here's the photographs here's the
eyewitness testimonial reports um
but at the end of the day you know we
still don't know what we're dealing with
so
i i'm not sure we're going to be able to
in a 74-page document
conclusively state
something is and satisfies people
satisfy people's curiosity
i think as time goes on and we continue
to look at this this enigma
and perhaps create a whole government
approach hopefully those reports each
year will become
increasingly uh more more uh
forthcoming and we'll have additional
details and fidelity
but i think it's just too early right
now look we just got to the point where
congress
and the american government agree that
these things are real so
how much can you possibly expect an
organization
uh in 180 days and by the way let's not
forget that that
the covet restrictions most of these
people could even go to work
um you know i i i try to be realistic
well to be fair some of your interviews
what i glean from them in an hour is
quite substantial so i can imagine that
if someone's given a team of people are
given 180 days they can come up with
what could
shock people that's you just said it if
you if you have a team of people
we they didn't have that the uap task
force was minimally manned
they had two people and they were only
part-time assigned so so that part of
the argument
isn't you know it hasn't been
substantiated and the other part is 180
days
i would submit to you it takes as i've
said before longer to remodel a kitchen
sometimes
than 180 days you you you're asking the
entire intelligence community and the
department of defense
to collect the data synthesize the data
process the data
and then and then author the data and
then coordinate that data through all 18
agencies of the intelligence community
have it reviewed by the lawyers have it
signed sealed and delivered by the
secretary of defense then to the
director of national intelligence
and then finally on to congress uh and
oh by the way
there's you know coveted we got to deal
with so anything classified which most
of this report is classified
you can't do it until you get to go to
work right so it's i i think
you know we're really expecting a lot
it's almost like like
expecting mike tyson to to fight
in a boxing ring with with you know both
hands tied behind his back
um it's it's it's just not i don't see
how that's that's reasonable
he would still defeat me okay oh me too
i'm sure
as for the fidel you mentioned fidelity
and a question that's been brought up by
quite a few people
i don't have a single username to single
out is are there
videos pictures that you've seen that
are not so
grainy not so far away but instead up
close exact
let's say such that someone who is on
the fence about this issue would no
longer be on the fence
yeah and i think you're seeing that with
congress i mean there's there's videos
and photographs from reporting that i've
been privy to
that are extremely compelling i've said
for the record that the three videos
that have come out as interesting as
they are they're probably the least
compelling of the ones that that
you know we we had and and this is why
i'm so concerned about now the recent
revelations that
the pentagon has deleted or destroyed my
emails and my
my my files because there were documents
on in a very comprehensive shared folder
that we had
that was was that was you know pretty
incredible
i mean there was some some very high
definition high fidelity videos in there
that when you looked at it you realize
hey
you know that's that's not one of our
aircraft many in the audience had one
more question with regard to this issue
which is why now why all these
revelations from the government all of a
sudden
because we weren't able to get to it
over the livestream i emailed him and
his assistant got back
saying as for your question why now why
not now
nothing will ever change nothing will
change if a few brave men and women
don't stand up to speak out about what
they know
lou has talked about this many times in
many interviews he was trying to raise
the alarm about this issue but it wasn't
getting reported up the chain of command
to the secretary of defense
in the u.s defense community if someone
is frustrated with bureaucracy there is
no way to circumvent the chain of
command so it's typical for those people
to resign
and then it's often the resignation
letter which finally makes its way up
the chain to effect
change that's exactly what happened in
lou's case feel free to reference
previous interviews that he's given
where he's answered this question
have there been any investigations as to
the connection between remote viewing
and uap so you can interpret that the
way you'd like
wow great question um
historically yeah that there was there
was some effort particularly in the in
the 70s and the 80s
during a program that one of my
colleagues was responsible for
uh the stargate program and before that
it was real flame and before that a
bunch of other names but
uh dr harold budo can can
probably give you some more information
on that during our time in a tip we
didn't really
focus on that we were more focused on
the nuts and bolts
but yeah there was you know there was
some some interesting information
that was put out uh in the past about
about that about the
the the connection between remote
viewing and potential uav activity there
was one
i think alleged uh remote viewing
session
where they were remote viewing a
particular enemy target
uh c seaborn the sea based target i'm
not going to go into more detail in that
i don't know if i can but apparently
there was some sort of
uap activity associated with that now
the problem is when you're talking about
remote viewing it's it's
it's very subjective and so you have to
be very careful
uh when you're dealing with data like
that because
it's at the end of the day you need more
information
uh you need information to substantiate
that's that may be one piece of the
puzzle but
by no means can you put together the
entire mosaic with just one piece of the
puzzle
you need all the pieces to really really
you know
understand what you're looking at you
mentioned someone's name
about a minute ago harold what was his
last name kutov
okay yeah i have a question about that
from jeremy riss of the channel alien
scientist
he wants to know have you ever heard of
something called the invisible college
and then as a secondary question was
this
theoretical physicist who brought you
into the program you mentioned this
before that someone brought you in to
atip
was it hal put off i'm very well aware
of
the the term invisible college uh i am
also very well aware of how
hal is a dear friend of mine he did not
bring me into this program
uh but we wound up uh working as as
colleagues
he he's an incredible human being him
another individual named dr kit green
uh another fantastic human being an
absolute american treasure
and there's a couple others dr eric
davis there's another one
i really was very fortunate i had the
opportunity to
to truly stand on the shoulders of
giants um
it was an incredible honor and there's
many others that i
i won't mention right now but dr colin
kelleher and a bunch of others that were
you know really
really helpful uh in the early days of
this effort
what is it that you've heard about the
invisible college that you can reveal
that you feel like is credible
i just heard the term yesterday i mean
uh it's
you know it's a loose affiliation of
individuals um you know
that's the term invisible uh college
being that these are individuals who
obviously have a high
uh academic vitae uh to their name
um you know it's it's more of a loose
affiliation
necessarily than a uh you know a
formalized
uh corporation um
you know it's that you might also hear
terms like the aviary
which uh you know there's there's some
truth to that there are some individuals
that belonged to an organization
and uh to to to remain anonymous
uh they had uh names of birds associated
with them
names of birds birds right that's the
term aviary
and what it did is it gave them an extra
degree of anonymity
uh when when having discussions uh you
know especially over
open lines or the email unsecured email
um
you know that that that's it's just a
layer extra layer of operation what we
call opsec
speaking of academia this question comes
from professor
of astronomy brian keating who runs the
into the impossible podcast
is there any test or data that would
convince you that every uap
sighting has a prosaic natural or
scientific explanation
i.e anything that could falsify the
narrative that alien technology is
visiting the earth now i know
we can put a clause to that and say
whether or not they're visiting or
whether or not they're from a dimension
that is you me may not like the term
dimension
in the way that it's used in common
parlance but
we can couch whether or not it's
visiting you understand what's meant by
the term aliens yeah i do so kurt i'm
gonna
ask you a favor to repeat that question
one more time
because there's there's a bit of a
contradiction in there
sure sure great great this comes from
professor of astronomy brian keating who
runs the into the impossible podcast
which i recommend you all
check out and subscribe to is there any
test or data that would convince you
that
every uap sighting has a prosaic natural
or scientific explanation
i.e anything that could falsify the
narrative that alien technology is
visiting
the earth so interesting
natural or scientific prosaic
explanation and then turns around and
says i.e
disproves some sort of alien visitation
i'm not sure the two are mutually
exclusive i i think
you know i i think you can have a
discussion about alien life and still
remain scientific we're doing it now
with nasa looking for microbial life on
mars
they're not exclusive you can't say in
one hand you know there's a scientific
explanation
but it's not but it disproves alien life
scientific explanation
may wind up actually proving alienware
if there is so
so i i i think that's f i think that
with all due respect i think that's
false logic um i don't i don't know
against mr keating at all i'm sure
uh you know you want a thorough answer
which i'm going to try to do my best
but the very notion that an alien life
form
can't be scientific look this planet is
probably the greatest ufo that we know
of
right this ball called earth hurtling
through deep space around a
you know obscure star we call the sun an
obscure part of the milky way has got
life all over the place in fact the
birth of science was right here
uh and it was it was the study of of of
other living
organisms look at darwin right so
so i i i think we need to be careful
when we
subscribe to the fact that if it's alien
it can't be scientific or if it's
scientific it can't be alien i don't
think the two are mutually exclusive
i think um we we realize now
with with the understanding of
extremophiles
that life can defy a lot of our our our
definitions
and continues to define our definition
so we have to keep reinventing
new definitions of what a life form is
you know initially we thought all life
forms
were or something that were based on on
ultimately
on the building blocks of photosynthesis
we now realize that's not true there are
extremophiles that live in and survive
of chemosynthesis
in the deepest parts of our ocean a
completely different
way of obtaining nutrients from its
environment we also realize that the
the understanding that life form must
have dna we now realize may not be true
also
in the world of virology we see all the
time viruses which can replicate and
behave very much like a living thing
and yet have no dna associated they have
rna
so uh i think we have to be careful
when we ask questions especially as
scientists
we have to make sure that we
to really embody the essence of science
we have to be willing to ask the hard
questions because that's the only way
science really advances
otherwise we would be stuck thinking
that the four elements of the earth are
earth wind fire and water
you know we've now realized this thing
called the periodic table we now realize
this thing called salt
you know uh subatomic particles and
quantum physics
had we have just stuck to that as being
science and not challenging the
ecosystem of science at the time
we never would be here we never would
have had newtonian physics we never
would have
einstein's relativity we wouldn't have
quantum physics so
again i caution one more time against uh
the the idea that that the science is
that science and a science
scientific explanation will
automatically rule out something alien
now
i think what he was trying to say uh
your your friend mr keating and i and i
forgive you through going this long with
you sure go ahead and i appreciate how
you're taking notes i appreciate
the seriousness to what you're answering
these questions
i think what he's probably saying asking
me is hey lou
is is there any examples that you can
say
that a you have found a prosaic
explanation for something that initially
seemed
unidentified or perhaps you know
extraordinary the answer is absolutely
yes
we have in fact that was the intent of
agent to go into something trying to
find
is this a drone is this some sort of
cruise missile is this some sort of
new type of aircraft or helicopter or
blimp or durable
you know you know atmospheric anomaly
you name it fill in the blank
is there a checklist by the way that one
goes through like is it a lens flare
is it a drone yeah there's absolutely
and you have when you have the experts
that are you know experts
in in those particular fields such as
photography or video
or whatever they're going through that
mental checklist is an artifact right uh
so this is a software glitch is it a
lens flare is it a
a scratch on the lens that now is being
uh hyper magnified and so you get
you know this weird uh scattering of
light effect it looks like you have a
real object there when you don't right
uh and so that's when you compare it to
the infrared that's when you compare it
also to the radar when you compare it to
the eyewitnesses right because
you know there's a when you have that
that amount of information now all
verifying that something is real then
you know you can start scratching up the
fact that it's some sort of artifact or
you know lens flare etc etc um
you know that there were times where we
were able to do that and said it's a bit
satisfying because you can kind of take
that off the list what what
for us was so difficult were the ones
that felt so far beyond
what we would normally presume as
capable capabilities that we have in
inventory again
the instantaneous acceleration
hypersonic velocities
uh trans-medium travel and you know
seemingly anti-gravity without
associated technologies no wings control
surfaces
no obvious signs of propulsion uh no
heat signature and yet these things are
able to defy
you know are the natural effects of
earth's gravity
those are the ones where you say okay
now we're not probably dealing with you
know
a helicopter we're not deal there's no
road or wash there's no heat signature
there's nothing at all
that that that we can look at with the
multiple sensors that we're looking at
something and say yeah that
that fits within the paradigm of you
know our existing
aviation technology um so there you have
it i didn't mean to again go into a
long-winded conversation very
long-winded man i'm a meticulous person
i also noted that you said
mental checklists is what they go
through and i was curious if due
diligence is a
physical checklist or a standardized one
a formalized one
yes but but those depending on where
that expertise resides
so if you're asking for example a cia
analyst who's an expert in
[Music]
optics they're going to go through their
own checklist differently than a radar
person who's an expert in radar uh and
telemetry who's gonna go through their
checklist so
you know there's not one single
checklist because depending on the
expertise that's being used and
leveraged it's like considered
talking to a cardiologist versus a
radiologist right right right right
medical doctors but they're not going to
go through the same checklist
you know when looking at someone's heart
you know once looking at it from
from an x-ray perspective one's looking
at it you know maybe from a
from a more from a biological and
metabolic process perspective so
those checklists exist but they're not
consistent across the board
you mentioned trans medium as well i'm
curious if you've seen any footage
where a uap goes from air to water and
is there a splash
involved or do they just submerge as if
it's
an illusion let's say or an artifact of
light not saying that they are artifacts
of light i'm just curious if they
displace the water
in any formidable fashion yeah well kurt
there seems to be some sort of
interaction
i will i will state that there's been
been plenty of reports that we have
where the water seems to be deterred
that there is a disturbance
over the water uh and there's several
hypothesis that had been proposed before
that
um no different that when you have a
helicopter hovering over the water you
can see the water being a bit perturbed
from the rotor wash
uh yet these all have rotor wash but but
the water seems to be
perturbed roiling if you will and we've
seen that over and over again not just
with the nemesis
there's some incidents near near upper
coast of puerto rico
there's been some other incidents as
well where where
the the reporting by government
officials has been that there is some
sort of disturbance in the water
the question is what is causing those
disturbances if you look at biology for
example look at an alligator we just now
realized over the last maybe decade or
two
that there are ulf ultra low frequencies
acoustic signatures that are
emitted by alligators when they are in
mating season
in the rivers and the lakes and you can
actually see as they put their head up
you can't hear it but the water begins
to
what looks like a dance around around
them and what's happening is these ultra
low frequencies acoustic frequencies
are are perturbing the water disturbing
the water and
the metrics that the matrix of the water
is is
part of and so it begins to to to roil
uh you know is this something similar it
could be we don't we don't know yet
because we don't understand the
technology before
you know but we we suspect that this
this disturbance in the water
could be a well
you know could be result of of the
technology being being utilized
uh you know no different than a
helicopter perhaps with its rotor wash
perturbing the water but rather than
being a physical or mechanical
disturbance it might be
due to some sort of electromagnetic
interference
right lou i wanted to thank you for how
open you are how frank you are
i'm not actually i'm not used to that
when when i speak to people
about this topic so firstly thank you
about that
well i look kurt i don't have all the
answers and i'm going to tell you that
you know you're asking me direct
questions i'll give you direct answers
i'll do that i'll do the best that i can
uh but you know i i don't have all the
answers
and i'm not i'm not afraid to say that
i'm not afraid and some are classified
as well
yeah and some details are definitely are
you know since you can't get out
right and for the people watching in the
chat if i don't get to your question
please it's because i'm in the moment
with lou
i don't want to keep switching tabs i
want to listen to lou's answer and ask
pertinent follow-up questions okay man
by the way for the record if i can just
real short let me go back
your friend mr keating i i didn't mean
any disrespect by that please make sure
he knows that
i just wanted to answer his question to
the best of my ability i wasn't trying
to
to to this wasn't a slam in any way i
just uh
i just wanted to be as accurate as
possible for sure for sure
manny ortez asks lou once said on a
podcast that someone from the pentagon
told them that they knew
that these that this phenomenon are
demons
although lou didn't seem to believe it i
would love for lou to
expand on that well kurt let me ask you
this
um you know what what is a demon
right i think most people would would
submit to you that a demon is
some sort of supernatural being that is
based in some sort of
religious doctrine uh and is usually you
know malevolent to some degree
um but you know let's let's look at this
from scientific perspective
all things by definition are
supernatural until
they're they're explained till they're
normal right this cellular telephone i'm
speaking to you on
this the wi-fi signals a hundred years
ago would be completely supernatural
and yet in some parts of the world
actually if i show a picture you know of
somebody then
that's still supernatural they think the
soul is is locked in the photograph
everything is is is
until it becomes normal everything is
supernatural until it becomes natural
and that is that is the definition of it
it just means beyond our understanding
of you know what what's before us
um i can't you know i can't tell anybody
with a straight face that something is
or is not demonic
because it really depends on what is
your definition of a demon
and at the end of the day you know i've
seen enough demons in my life in combat
and warfare to know that you know there
really is true evil in this world
a lot of it is man-made but um you know
i uh i can't i can't discount that i i
don't personally
believe that myself but
you know i'm a big firm believer of know
thy enemy
if it turns out that these things are
demonic at least we know
you know i'd rather know than than to
guess
um you know do i subscribe to that line
of thinking that these are demons
no not particularly what about angels
great question saying it's exactly the
same thing angels and demons you know
supernatural beings that that that we
can't explain that that seem to
to to fall outside of the realm of
of of what we consider being normal
human behavior and normal human
capabilities
um okay let me steal man the question
let me steal a minute
when i say steel man hopefully you're
familiar with the term what i'm i think
what the person is getting at is that
let's imagine let's presuppose in a
certain world view that there's a deity
that created the universe with intent
and one of the
first creatures they created were
powerful beings that have divine powers
some of those are angels some of those
are demons and then
humans were created or let's say the big
bang was set off and then humans were
created
via the process of evolution so do you
see
or do you see evidence or do you
have friends with an atip who believe
that those are
demons in that sense or angels in that
sense even
um i didn't see that in eight
um but i did see it in dod leadership
um you know i i i
certainly am not going to confront
someone's spiritual beliefs about
something
you know the word angel comes from the
word angelios
of of light of fire think of helios the
sun
right or something um these are terms
that that
that have been given to to to
explain supernatural beings and
occurrences
in in you know during our existence
um you know i i am for what i i
despite being a scientific man i am i am
a very much spiritual
um i don't wear my religion on my sleeve
but i don't think that the topic
of uaps uh or even potentially
extraterrestrials
is necessarily against the idea of
organized religion when i went to rome
not too long ago and a half ago maybe
uh and spoke to some very senior
academics in the vatican
they they told me that that in the 1600s
had you have
told people there was no such thing as
aliens that would be considered heresy
because there is no there is no limit to
the dominion of god
or the notion of god and it's only been
in relative recent history that
we have put these limitations on what
god can and can't do you know
there can't be aliens because we have to
be the most you know the divine
most divine representation of god um
you know so i i i find that topic
fascinating
especially as it relates to theology and
philosophy and even sociology
our reaction to it as a species um
but i i i did not come into contact with
that
and if and if it was an atip it was kept
hidden from from us
no one no one talked about that no one
seemed to have any type of religious
aversion
looking into this topic all right the
next question comes from bisect docs
have we intercepted communication
between uaps and or has there been
communication with
uaps i'm not aware of any
uh interception of communications with
uaps
as far as communication with uaps you
know once again i hate to split hairs
here i don't want to upset anybody but
let's
let's be specific what is communicating
i mean you and i are having a
conversation in english and we're
communicating but
if i stand behind uh a wall and i
i aim an assault rifle at you am i
communicating with you yeah i am i'm
communicating
an intent or a threat right if a dog
growls and shows its teeth to you
as you try to kneel down and pet it is
it communicating yeah it's communicating
it's telling you hey you know i don't
want to be pet right now i don't don't
don't don't touch me so you know um
if if a uap is is uh
behaving in a provocative manner meaning
it's it's it's uh
um obviously knows that where or are
aware that it is there
and doesn't seem to mind doesn't seem to
try to hide itself in some cases it's
been perhaps
uh hovering uh over over you know one of
our military equities for for
a prolonged period of time is that
communication well i would submit to
yes it's probably communication it's not
verbal communication
but but it's signaling some sort of
intent yes i know you're there and yes i
know you know that i'm here
and i'm okay with that and now i want
you to know that i'm here now
the rationale what's the reasoning
intent behind it we don't know but that
is communication
if you know when when we when we do a
show of force
uh and if you know we fly an sr-71 at a
hundred thousand feet and we don't want
the enemy to see us
but if i take a couple f-22 raptors and
i fly off the coast of let's say
uh uh disputed territory in the south
china sea
i'm communicating with with a country it
may not be through dialogue but
make no mistake i'm i'm communicating
very clearly and very effectively my
intent
um to to another to another party and so
um i think there lies the question are
these things
trying to communicate with us and if so
uh
do will we be smart enough to recognize
it as as
as some sort of communication uh versus
just
you know uh two ships passing the night
i
i do think that the more brazen that
these these incidents become the more
there may be an attempt to try to
communicate
obviously whatever it is is aware that
we are
there and we are aware that they're
there
are you aware of any more or of any less
coarse-grained communication
for example we can communicate with the
cheetah like you mentioned we can point
a gun at it or we can
show our hostility or our civility is
there
verbal as far as you know has there been
any verbal or even telepathic direct
communication i'm sorry my audio just
cut out
has there been any verbal or telepathic
communication i know that there's a
story about
i think zimbabwe africa with aliens
communicating with some children there's
certainly reports of it doesn't mean
that it's it's it's
see the problem is subjective we don't
know for sure it's
it's the humans interpretation of what's
going on and and here
is why we have to be so careful as you
know in a scientific experiment and in a
closed system
you know the the the the the
likelihood of human error is increased
significantly
and so uh you know we have to be
cognizant of that
um is there some sort of real
communication as you say telepathic
communication occurring
or is it uh a similar effect to let's
say taking a hallucinogenic
drug and having some sort of experience
right
mental experience i don't know the
answer to that
the answer could be yes or no for none
it could be that there there
there is it's just our it's uh our
impression of what's going on
uh and it's not real right like the
near-death experience a lot of people
report it being real a lot of people say
no it's just
parts of the mind that are beginning to
shut down and you start you know having
these experiences
i don't think anybody really knows for
sure other than the people who actually
experienced it
when you talk to them they feel very
compelled that they've had a real event
and i'm not i don't doubt for one minute
they
actually believe they've had some sort
of communication and by the way that
could be the case
right again there's no way to prove it
or disprove it so it's it's interesting
um but we didn't focus that on about
that part of
it because it's it's it's too subjective
you can't quantify and qualify that data
like you can with radar data
and photographic evidence et cetera so
uh it wasn't
it wasn't particularly useful i'm saying
it's not interesting
it just wasn't useful for our calculus
as to the connection between
psychedelics and aliens or psychedelics
and uaps
you're unaware of any credible
verifiable falsifiable data
well look i mean now we're getting into
the world of consciousness
you know and i would submit to you it's
not everything we do a result of of
of a conscious process occurring in our
brain
um you know by very definition
everything i do in life is a result
of some sort of willful intent based
upon a consciousness process occurring
in my brain just like you and everybody
else
so um you know we realize that that
human consciousness is is an area that
we're just now beginning to explore and
and we understand even less is it
possible that human consciousness is
part of a universal consciousness
and that we can tap into this is it's
not it's not
human consciousness is not only for
humans possibly i mean
there's people out there who have pet
cats and dogs on one of them where
you know you have a connection with your
pet not because it's
just a cat or a dog but because you
there's something deeper
that you are you are connecting with
something far more intimate something
far more sacred
than just a you know a furry little bag
of skin and you know hair balls
there's there's there's something and by
the way that life form recognizes you as
well as a sentient being there's this
appreciation
that hey we're on the same wavelength i
may not look like you i mean i'll act
like you were talk like you but
we're kind of the same thing we're both
conscious sentient beings
and we recognize that in each other um
you know and it's that they also may
explain uh human interactions as well
so consciousness may not be
um something that is that is only uh
you know owned and defined by the human
species
is it possible there's other things if
we can communicate with dolphins and
cats and dogs and birds and you know
gorillas
maybe human consciousness isn't quite so
maybe it's not so special maybe it's
indelible maybe it's something that's
part of
part of all of nature and when i say all
the nature even beyond this planet
perhaps
the next question comes from mick west
i'd like to ask
lou elisondo does i'll just read this
verbatim
if he really thinks this is non-human
technology that can revolutionize the
world and maybe
include contact with aliens and
extra-dimensional beings and so on why
is he so
concerned with ndas surely for the good
of humanity he should release the
evidence
that he has ah surely for the good of
humanity and then
he can go ahead and pay for my mortgage
he can put my kids through school he can
come visit me every day and give me soup
while i'm behind bars
spending the next 40 years of my life uh
you know doing a service for for for
somebody else i've already put my neck
on the line
uh so i'll do respect mr west um you
know uh if
why don't you there's nothing stopping
you why don't you do it you know i've
already put my career
my my reputation credibility on the line
i've already forgotten my
my retirement and my pension how much
more else do you expect me to sacrifice
you want me to put myself up on a cross
and nail myself to it
just just because you know i think we've
come pretty far so far i think i think
i haven't had to go to jail and we've
come pretty damn far in the last three
years
you know so i guess a simple you're
welcome uh
is probably you know would be my
response are there whistleblower
protection acts that you could reveal
information under
oh this is part of the ig process this
is part of
of congress you know there are people
that i can speak with without violating
my non-disclosure agreement
that can further the conversation you
know and this is what we're trying to
exercise i mean i
i've tried to be as clear as i can with
our roadmap moving forward without
jeopardizing it
but if people notice one thing about me
is that we're you know
i'm deliberate i don't do anything
haphazard so all the stuff that people
are now seeing with conversations and
congress and ig
do people honestly think that's just
some sort of coincidence
i mean guys look if you look at what
i've been saying the last three years
you're going to see a pattern
it's very clear it you guys everything
i've said has come to fruition
lock stock and barrel you know this is
we're trying to do this the right way
and as i said before there's a
difference between doing things right
and right now
and i prefer to do things right you know
this is a process i told people from day
one
you know if you're expecting instant
gratification then you know go go take
up something else go take a finger
painting don't don't do this because
this this is going to be a long term
effort
and and and it's it's every day the due
diligence of what we're doing but it's
making a difference just look at the
last three years how far we've come
we have an official uap task force we
have the government admitting that ufos
are real
we have congress being briefed at the
classified level they're all coming out
things important
we actually have the task force now
providing information to congress and
180 day report
we have other countries like japan
coming out and reaching out and wanting
to
to share their information with us i
mean man how much more do you want in
three years
you know so again forgive me for being a
little bit
you know testy about this i think
questions like that annoy you do you get
them frequently and you're tired of them
well you know what it's it's armchair
quarterbacking it's it's easy for people
to sit back i see it all the time on
social media just violate your nda
leader it's okay
you you go to jail for us it's okay but
they're not willing to do
you know one-tenth of that sacrifice for
this effort
if you ask them hey get off your ass and
go go talk to your congressman or
you know start start doing research and
start going out and and
and and being a a force multiplier for
this effort
they want i'm too tired i got too much
go i'm too busy well i got my family to
take care of well
so do i i'm not different why why
am i being held to a different standard
why am i have to be you know the person
coming out there and just
say hell to everybody and wind up having
to go run
and hide in some foreign country and
never come back to my country i love my
country
by the way my non-disclosure agreement i
took was a promise i made to the
american people
not my government and so i think it's
really disingenuous to say well you can
just break your promise this time
to for the for the truth no i can't
that's why i said well you can cheat on
your wife this
only this time or or you know you can
you can cheat on your family this time
it won't matter yes it does matter every
time matters it's a promise that's what
a promise is either
either you're a man of your word or a
woman of your word or you're not
otherwise they're called principles and
and people fight and die for those
principles and
you know i've seen people fight and die
for those principles
you know they're not just something that
you conveniently throw around i promise
to do this and then really later on say
no i don't really promise
you know that's that's not the way
promises work
those are the kind of people that don't
survive in combat because
people have your back you know you you
you swear an oath of an allegiance to do
the right thing that's
that's what this is about you know i i
don't understand people who can just say
hey go ahead and break your promise this
one time
i mean what are you talking about you'd
never trust me again
i can't break this one time because the
one time i do then i could do it a
thousand times
and at that point i might as well throw
in the towel so
anyways let me let me push back i'm like
i'm on your cam i'm on your side man so
let me just be friendly and push
back with regard to breaking a promise
to me this seems like the difference
between
as jesus said the spirit of the law
versus the text of the law
so do you see an obligation to the
spirit of the law
rather than the text so the text says
you have to obey this promise
well he also said follow the law of the
land too didn't he and so
you know the law of the land here is
that he took an oath and a promise to
the american people
and i'm not going to violate that
promise it's you can't break a promise
to fulfill a promise
it doesn't work that way please let me
push back gently
okay this is something i've been
thinking about sometimes
trust needs to be broken in order for it
to be regained in the long term stronger
so for example you mentioned cheating
on a spouse sometimes one has to come
clean and say i did cheat
in order for the relationship to
eventually be repaired even though that
in the short run is going to be far
worse wouldn't it be better not to cheat
at all and not have to do that
yeah you're right you need to if you
cheat you need to you need to admit you
cheated but
but isn't it better just not to cheat
and you don't have to worry about that
i agree okay so in this analogy in this
analogy the cheating would be
let's say let's say you had some piece
of information
that says that our world is vastly
different and potentially even dangerous
or wasteful on behalf of the government
do you see a sense of duty to the
citizens
to break your oath i know you say that
it's the oath with the citizens
themselves but
you understand where i'm going with this
but you don't have to there are
mechanisms in place
that that you don't have to break that
oath to fulfill a promise
that's what i'm trying to say here it's
not an either or it just takes more time
by the way it's a lot more
yeah it takes more time but but it's the
right way to do it
that's that's that is the correct way to
do it
than just going ahead and and
you know i i i can't i won't be able to
live with myself doing that
no one will ever take me seriously again
nobody could ever trust me if i break
that promise just that one time
that's not the way it works so you know
i i think the proof is in the pudding
and you know honestly i'm look otherwise
i'm not gonna break it so people can
keep asking me all day long
and they're wasting their oxygen because
i am not going to break that promise i
will not violate
my non-dispute disclosure agreement got
it and by the way i'll tell you if it
comes
to the point where i have to actually
stop doing this
to maintain my promise i will i will
disappear you'll never hear from lou
again
if the option in between comes down to
me having to speak or having to
and break my promise or being quiet i
will be quiet i will not break my
promise
and if people can't accept that then you
know fi
talk to somebody else i don't know what
to tell you well i'm grateful that
you're
not quite right now and thank you for
speaking with me lonesome space cowboy
asks
i just have one question pretty
subjective but i'd like to hear his take
if the general public knew and saw what
lewis knows and has seen
what would the world look like for the
next week after that how would the
public react
so this is you can surmise wow
what a thoughtful question um
boy i have no idea kurt that that that's
um
i would need to think about that okay we
can get back to that question
oh yeah i mean that's such a good
question i don't i don't want to just
throw out an answer
right i i want to think about that and i
might need i might need even a little
bit more time
i will for sure get back to you on that
but um
that's going to take some thought great
great
i'm going to take a question from the
audience so jenshin says tom delong
says that the occupants of the uaps are
called the others in quotation
do you know anything about this
that's what you want to name them but
but
i got my german shepherd is named
hercules you know but
you can call them whatever you want i
mean it's a name right
i don't you can you can
is he calling him the others do the
others call themselves others or
you know it it
i i would probably ask tom that question
i i i
i here's something i heard when i was
looking up some interviews with bob
lazar
that the aliens refer to us as
containers or at least he read that he
can't
substantiate it have you heard this and
what do you make of it
not a clue and who is that you said was
that bob lazar you said
yeah i i can't speak for mr lazar i've
never met the man i don't know
he was not part of the effort and
therefore i can't i can't
expound upon that i wouldn't even know
where to begin with that i have no idea
between you and i this is like a foray
for me because my background is in
physics and math
and i had no idea that people were so
divisive when it comes to bob lazar and
just
individuals in this ufo community in
general that if you say you believe them
then you're ostracized or if you say
that you don't believe them you're also
ostracized by a certain
subset do you have views on bob lazar
whether you find him incredible i've
never met him i don't know his
background i don't know his story
i do know george knapp he's very
credible uh
i i don't know anything more than i
guess george knapp
may have helped break the story at one
point um but i don't know mr lazar
and out of due respect for mr lazar and
his family and those
friends colleagues those the community
um i i don't have a comment
you know it's it's that's part of the
problem people
people offer a lot of what they think
instead of what they know and so when
you mention someone like that
uh people automatically you know well i
think this i think that
well okay i respect that but the
question is what do we know
and right now i don't know a whole lot
about mr bazar so it's it's not fair for
me to really
provide any any type of opinion one way
or the other
you're watching this channel because
you're interested in theoretical physics
consciousness and the ostensible
connection between the two what's
required to follow some of these
arguments is
facility with mathematics as well as
discernment of the underlying physical
laws and
you may think that this is beyond you
but that's false brilliant provides
pelucid
explanations of abstruse phenomenon such
as quantum computing
general relativity and even group theory
when you hear that the standard model is
based on u1 cross su-2 cross su-3
that's group theory for example now this
isn't just for neophytes either for
example
i have a degree in math and physics and
i still found some of the intuitions
given in these lessons
to vastly aid my penetration into these
subjects for example electricity and
magnetism sign up today at brilliant.org
toe that is t-o-e for free you'll also
get 20
off the annual premium subscription try
four of the lessons at least don't
stop before four and i think you'll be
greatly surprised at the ease at which
you comprehend subjects you previously
had trouble grocking
links are in the description pulsating
shadow asks how frequently do abductions
happen among civilians
military personnel and is there
substance to the rumor of human
mutilation
i also want to ask you about cattle
mutilation at some point but
that's that um well
uh you know abductions is something we
we didn't really look at
because it's again too subjective we're
relying on the human being
to give us data uh with without anything
else really substantiating that other
like unlike radar data and
gun camera footage um i'm aware of a lot
of those reports
but but i don't have a comment either
way i simply don't know um
and as interesting as it may be it's not
it wasn't overly helpful
to the perspective of of our efforts
native to the specific calculus we were
working on remember what is it and how
does it work
um that really didn't come into play
now as far as human mutilation um that's
another topic that i'm completely
unqualified
to to to discuss because i simply don't
know
um certainly if that is the case then
then we are dealing with a potential
threat possibly hostile intent
because from where i come from as a
former investigator and special agent
that's a crime first of all it's called
kidnapping second of call
second of all it's called assault um you
know and and
third of all it may even be in an
extreme case it could be considered you
know
first degree premeditated murder so you
know
i i i don't know anything about that
really um
you know i am aware of the cattle
mutilations a little bit more because
i've spoken to some veterinarians and
some doctors um you know there's a lot
of prosaic explanations i think it's
fascinating it's interesting
but i'm not a certified medical doctor
nor coroner so i can't
i can't look at a cadaver of a of a
bovine of
a cow and say the lips were removed with
a surgical precision without any type of
heat ablation or authorization uh and
yet you know
it was it was a perfect clean cut
there's no bleeding i
i don't know what can cause that i don't
know if there's a natural process i can
explain that i
haven't seen one but maybe there is
could it be predatory behavior of
coyotes uh
eating that part of the meat that is
most rich in nutrients or accessible
i i don't i don't know the answer um or
is it something else
you know there's a lot of people who say
there's there's perhaps something else
to it
again i i don't really know this one
comes from lady shar
reacts mr elizondo do you think there
was another craft under the water but
that was causing the uap
disturbance that commander fravor
reported
great question it's exactly what we're
trying to figure out what there's some
other stories that are going to come to
light from other incidents
that are going to be i think fairly
riveting when people find out uh
you know that what's occurred
uh in and around some of our military
operations
um it's it's possible there could be
something underneath the water
it could also be a uh like i said a
reaction to the to the technology being
employed
um by whatever on top of the water we we
don't know yet um
i think we're getting a little bit
closer to answering that of course if we
can get some some sonar data
uh to validate maybe there's some
something in the water at the same time
as we see something in the air
that would be very helpful in
substantiating that
amjad hussain who actually sponsors the
podcast
with his company algo asks are any alien
bodies in possession of the us
government
so mr hussein again great question uh
it's a question a lot of people want to
know and it's a question that i can't
answer
because i i haven't been privy to that i
do not know if there's any type of
biological organisms
that uh that are in possession of the us
government i i do believe as i've said
before for the record that we are in
possession of material
and we'll go and we'll elaborate into
more than that um
but as far as having biological
specimens it's something that i
i can't answer and i don't want to
mislead anybody i don't want to say
i think because it doesn't matter what i
think what matters is
what the facts say so forgive me sorry
no no problem
man i'm just i'm having a blast man
thank you so much i've been
burning the midnight oil man so i do
apologize well
i know you have a hugely busy schedule
and so even for a modicum of your time
i'm
immensely grateful and personally i'm
curious if
what's going on at skinwalker did atip
study that
and i know you don't like to espouse but
what do you
what do you think is going on there
sub question let me say before i forget
it and then i wanted to know
what is there a connection between
bigfoot and ufos because there seems to
be
a confluence of that at skinwalker at
least
so uh i i worked with colleagues that
were focused on the awesome and the skin
walker
uh phenomena what i what i can say is
that
they are very convinced and and i think
i am too that there are things that
probably go bump in the night
that probably need further explanation
uh but but that isn't that was not my
portfolio
and i don't want to speak to that
because i simply don't know
um that was done at a time with with the
tremendous efforts of mr bigelow and
and the former director uh asap director
uh and a lot of folks uh from from
bigelow aerospace
and you know the data was very
compelling i'll say that
it was absolutely compelling and i think
mr brandon fugle now and others
have recognized the validity of some of
that data
um but uh that's that's all i'm prepared
to say about that as far as bigfoot i'm
gonna share something with you
and i i hope i hope that this doesn't
turn anybody off
um it's probably gonna turn me on
um i had the great honor and privilege
of speaking with some people
from the first nations saskatchewan
indigenous people
uh the lakota and dakota bands
these are individuals who are fiercely
proud
uh have an incredible heritage and
[Music]
have nearly ten thousand years of oral
tradition
okay in in this continent uh and they
have an incredible connection to the
land
and uh i was asked by by someone there
uh and i'm not gonna say who it was but
a very senior individual who was
associated with the first nations people
and he asked me he said i want to ask
you a question lou have you ever seen
sasquatch
i said no sir
so i'm going to ask you one more time
are you sure you've never seen sasquatch
sir i
i've never seen scene scout for
sasquatch and he said well
that's good because from my people's
perspective sasquatch
is a spirit that protects our women and
children
and a spirit of the forest and if you
see a man see sasquatch it means your
heart isn't pure
and i wasn't prepared for that i was
like
holy smokes you're glad i haven't seen
sasquatch
interesting but yeah that was their
there was their take
uh very very interesting but who among
us have pure hearts
well that's that's a whole other
question right i don't think any of us
really do have pure hearts but
but the fact that that they see it that
way uh i found very
very interesting um it's it's very
unique perspective
and i think if anybody has a has a
has a right to have a narrative on
sasquatch it's certainly indigenous
people
so i i found that again i i can't tell
you whether or not that's true
i can just tell you what was told to me
but um
you know there you have it as for
skinwalker in general you just think
your statement is there is something
that's going bump in the night or you
think there is
nothing more can be said about that i'm
hugely interested in skinwalker
you know uh current at some point
more is to be revealed yeah you know i
it's
i i don't want to go down any rabbit
holes prematurely
um you know this this is a very
this is a very complex universe we live
and it's a system and uh
we're learning more and more about the
reality of life
and the transition of what
birth means and the transition of what
death means
and uh you know human consciousness and
human spirit
what not um and you know suffice it to
say
i we we probably really don't have a
very good handle right now
on on understanding um what lies beyond
our five senses
i've said this before we have five
fundamental senses for which we
we judge our environment and if you
can't touch it taste it hear it smell it
or you know
feel whatever it's it it doesn't exist
and yet the reality is 99.9 of the
universe
lies well beyond our our ability to
sense these things we have wi-fi signals
coursing through your body every moment
of every day we have cosmic radiation
coming from
the cosmos we've got neutrinos that are
flooding your body for the sun
we've got cellular signals and radar
signatures at the local airport
and all these are real and i tell people
if you want to know the reality of the
universe look at a night sky one night
and look how pretty it is
now take a radio telescope and look at
that same night sky look at it through
infrared look at it through
ultraviolet and you're going to see
things you've never seen before
and so by definition 99 of our
our noble universe we can't even
perceive and then when you look at the
scale of the universe
i've said this before if you look at you
know the group
i was corrected recently that the
visible galax that bills
the visible known universe is about 90
some
uh billion light years across even
though it's only been around
13.7 billion light years we think uh
that the actual
for the the seeable universe right now
around us is about 97 billion light
years
and as big as that is in terms of us
being this little tiny minute thing
stuck in the middle of it
there is equally that amount of space
relative space inside every one of us if
you look at an atom which is 1 times 10
to the minus 26 the size the mole
compare that to to the human body we
have that
same that same amount of space inside
every one of us there's a whole universe
inside of us and so
so the scale in which we live unless
something is 50 feet in front of our
face we'll
never be able to interact with anything
that is an order of magnitude above us
or below us
we can't even see the cells in our
bodies without a microscope so
so there are these realities all around
us that constantly that that exists and
that we are part of and yet
we cannot interact with and by that
definition
99.9 of the universe falls outside of
the realm of our perception so who's to
say that
that all of reality needs to fit neatly
within the very narrow spectrum of the
electro optical electro-optical
frequency that we call visible light
when we know that that's not true same
thing with acoustic same thing with
electromagnetic same
thing with everything and i think it's
foolhardy for science to presume that
that everything can be explained through
the fundamental five senses in the scale
in which we live because we know that's
not true look at dark energy
and dark matter most of the universe
can't even be seen all right even the
fundamental forces
who knows right right strong force weak
force electromagnetism right so
so you know i i think we need to
remember if you are truly a scientist we
must remain
open to the fact that that we are
judging our environment
through a very very narrow lens uh
it's like watching a sitting up on the
bleachers
watching a football game at the very
very highest part of a bleachers and
watching the whole game through a soda
straw
you're gonna miss most of it you know so
that would be my
that'd be my uh my two cents emil esses
thanks
thank louis for me without him we
wouldn't be where we are today
with regard to this matter and mr roboto
also says thank you mr
elisando for the service for your
service to this country
oh my pleasure you know what everybody
serves in their own way
uh if you're a taxpayer you're serving
if you are a school teacher you're
serving if you're a nurse you're serving
if you're a police officer
you're you're a person military uniform
you know uh if you're a lawyer
and and you decide to take a case pro
bono because it's the right thing to do
guess what you're serving so
so thank you for for for all those out
there who continue to serve
no it's a great honor and privilege to
be to be speaking with you here today
thank you man andreas says hey lou are
there questions
you think that the public hasn't been
asking that we ought to be
what should we be asking
i'm just going to be flipping for a
second but now let's go go ahead go
ahead go ahead
um no i think you're on the right track
i think people are asking the right
questions um i i i do i think people are
i think i think people are coming around
to to
reality of this new paradigm
and that's good that's okay that's a
good thing
you know otherwise we stagnate as
species
jen hageni asks on april 30th i believe
of this year
in the basement office interview
lu said watch out for the next 30 days
now what
was he referencing
all of it a lot has happened in the 30
days
don't you give a breakdown for the
people like myself who are new to this
field that
have little clue imagine i'm clueless
which i am sure
uh you have uh very senior level
briefings happening to congress you have
congress wanting
potentially to do open hearings uh you
have an ig
evaluation underway uh to look at how
the government's been handling this
topic over the last three years
you have you've got quite a bit of
things happening right now we've got
foreign governments that haven't quite
come out yet that are beginning to
engage the united states
uh you have uh discussions on creating a
a long-term enduring capability to look
at the separate
government approach um okay
speaking about the world government not
that there is one but yeah and by the
way
i'm being told right now i've got i've
got just about a couple few more minutes
because my
i have another unfortunately one more
engagement that i have to do
that's no problem man okay apologies no
no no no problem i
appreciate the time that you've given so
blind arise asks all of this recent
disclosure and activity has been very
u.s
focused it would be interesting to know
if other countries are working on this
stuff too
or are cooperating at some level the
implication is that
whoever can reverse engineer this tech
first wins
but isn't our chance isn't it best to
give our chance to all humans
yes yes yes and yes yes i'm all four
parts yes uh uh
you know there are other countries
working on this yes there are other
governments that are reaching out to
work with us
uh yes that uh he who who
reveals the secret first has the
advantage and yes this would be better
for your humanity if we worked it all
together
mikhail mahal asks did atip look into
the uss
trepang photos from 1971 negative we did
not
neon dagger has louis ever had a
personal encounter whether it was close
up or at a distance
with an intelligence or some kind of or
some kind of machine i assume they were
referring to the uaps
that will be for another discussion okay
and i'll get to just two more quick
questions
okay paul sawford asks i would like his
take on the tic tac
movements at sea level actually forget
that question sorry paul
there's a better question
don't feel bad paul i would have
answered it
okay racing carlos asks could you ask
him about the nimitz case david fravors
said that david fravor said that the
tic-tac-shaped ufo after disappearing
from his view it appeared to the radar
operator
at his quote unquote cap point what does
this represent
how on earth did the ufo know the cap
point beforehand
great question uh we don't know how it
knew either that earth one hell of a
coincidence the cap point is a
rendezvous point
that is uh input into the flight plan of
the pilots and the uh
and the avionics systems of the aircraft
uh
in this case it was about 60 miles away
from their their location
uh where they encountered the tic tac
and within five seconds this thing
appeared over their cat point uh
seemingly
uh anticipating where they were supposed
to go and waiting for that
great question that uh is this some sort
of active exploitation of the avionics
uh or is this some sort of uh
predetermination understanding where the
plane was going to go because somehow it
understands space-time
in a different way that we do or was it
just a pure coincidence
we simply don't know and the last
question i asked you before which i'm
going to get back to
actually hunting here says sam harris
said that he was contacted by the former
dod slash intelligence
officials about some possible form of
disclosure was it lou
or melon
i'm sorry can you repeat that okay so
sam harris recently said
that he was contacted by someone from
the former dod intelligence
and he wants to know and sam harris was
talking about a possible form of
disclosure
was this person who contacted sam harris
i have no idea
and then i know you got to get going the
lonesome space cowboy remember that
last question that you couldn't get to
which was if the general public knew or
saw what you saw
how would they what would the next week
look like how would the public react
somber uh
i think there would be this uh
big exhale for about a day
and then this uh turning inward
and trying to reflect on what this means
to us and our species and ourselves
uh i think uh somber sorry
like a sigh of relief somber meaning
serious not not
like hollywood portrays people partying
in the streets and
silliness with that um i think you would
have
uh some people perhaps turning to
religion
more so you might have some people
turning away from them
i think you're going to have at that
point the the philosophical and
theological
uh questions will be raised
and and people will have some serious
soul-searching to do no pun intended
and i don't think that's bad by the way
um
i think uh a lot of folks that have
spent their times in this community
being charlatans will have been exposed
and uh they will be probably unemployed
and probably have to change their names
because
you know the rest of society will look
at them
in an unfavorable light um i think um
there are some unsung heroes that will
probably come to light
and uh the world will appreciate their
contributions to this topic
i think the scene typically academic
communities no i can't do business
i know what i was going to say is names
that have been announced before when you
say the unsung heroes or
new names haven't been announced before
okay uh
i think the scientific and academic
community is going to have to take a
real hard look at itself
uh and and uh see why it repeated the
same mistakes it did
when galileo first proposed that the
earth was not the center of the solar
system
uh you know hubris
is is is a big part of that um
and then i think you know maybe we start
the international conversation say okay
we realize that this
there's there's things out there that
are probably well beyond our petty
discrepancies we have with each other
um maybe we really need to start working
together on this
realize that we are really a global
family it doesn't matter
where you're from it doesn't matter what
your religion is or
culture or your color or anything else
we are we are all uh we are all brothers
and sisters on this tiny little rock car
you know this pale blue dot that's
hurtling through space
um we may unify us
well i would certainly hope so unless we
allow
our
poor nature to to interfere and we look
at this as
as opportunities to subjugate each other
i would hope i would hope that's not the
case
thank you so much do you have any advice
for me as someone investigating this
topic somewhat a new
and somewhat first keep pushing keep
pushing keep asking the questions
and be fearless um you know that is the
true scientific pioneering spirit
the ability to challenge the status quo
uh
and and be able to do so uh in in in a
courageous way
and in a well-meaning way um the true
enemy of science
is stagnation is acceptance of the norms
because we know that's not
real science changes our understanding
changes because we're human humans
change
so uh you know we need to continue to
pursue the truth
wherever that truth may be we need to
continue to pursue it
so if that'd be my advice thank you sir
i appreciate it what do you have to
promote where can the audience find out
more about you what's next for you
oh kurt i hate self-promoting man i'm
not that guy
you know i i hate even tweeting i do it
because i want to keep people engaged
because i i really appreciate
everybody's perspectives
um but uh you know
i just want to promote the truth
wherever that truth is a lot of people
don't realize i don't
i don't get paid for these these type of
things i'm actually taking off work to
do it because i believe in it so much
you're not paid by the government to
spread misinformation is that what you
say
oh yeah every day sure yeah i mean
that's that's what what certainly these
conspiracy theorists like to believe
anyways
you know uh by the way if that's the
case i'm sure not making a whole lot of
money doing it
um but uh you know all bs aside
no uh i'm not being hated
not being i'm not uh you know still
wearing my counter intelligence hat i'm
trying to deceive the american public
it's just that's that's just nonsense
that's that
same crap that has held that conspiracy
theory that's kelp kept the ufology
uh community behind for for 70 years
you know it's time to grow up you know
wake up and stop
stop uh thinking everybody's out to get
you you know yeah there's been some
mistakes done in the past but you know
people there's some people that actually
want to see
see the truth come out you know and
one of those guys if you don't like what
i have to say then don't listen you know
i'm not forcing anybody to tune in and
listen i'm not
you know forcing you to sit down on a
couch
you know if you don't like what i have
to say this is a free country thank god
you know
go tune into something else well i
listen to you
and hopefully once the dust settles we
can have a longer conversation
perhaps even in person once covet is
over i would love that kurt any time you
want would
be my honor thank you man you make me
feel giddy by
by saying that even if it's just
politeness thank you so much no i
listen people know me personally i am
that guy i i
i say what i mean if i say that we're
gonna do coffee we will
get damn sure we're gonna do coffee at
some point so i don't say these things
lightly
i mean what i say thank you lou have a
great one
i apologize for keeping you over time
thank you and just say hi to everyone
they're so happy to see you there's
let's see how many thank you to your
audience i hope i didn't offend anybody
that wasn't my intent
uh they're almost 3 000 people watching
right now wow
that's great well you know i've like i
said i've always told people i'm latin
uh i've got to have my coffee there's a
few things that we come out of the womb
having to to do and
strong coffee is one of them so i
apologize if i was a little bit uh
a little bit uh ornery today that wasn't
my intent but i'm gonna go get some
coffee i'll
fix myself right now all right man get
to it take care yes sir
take care everybody thank you so much
and uh god bless everybody
okay thank you all for attending
i'm going to go through some of the chat
i wasn't able to get to everyone's
questions
again for those who are new to this
channel this is not a ufo channel
per se i'm interested in something
called the theory of everything which is
is an approach in physics that tries to
unify all the fundamental forces and
find
the laws of the universe what governs us
and i'm
broadly interested in that which means
i'm interested in it from a theoretical
physics perspective
as well as from a philosophical
perspective perhaps even a psychological
perspective
though that one has only been explored
with someone named john vervicky on this
channel
thank you all thank you all there's so
many names i can't say thank you to
all of you and i appreciate it if you
all would like to see more conversations
like this
on a regular basis longer conversations
like this more intense conversations
like this
i try to keep it technical because
partially that's how my mind works and
also because i think that
to get to some of these truths as luis
elisondo says
a specific exact rigorous approach is
necessary there's plenty of
broad interviews fluff which i don't
demean at all
because they're great for getting an
over arching view
but i like to get down into the weeds if
you'd like to see more of that please
consider going to patreon.com
slash curt gymnal the link is in the
description of this
the link is also pinned each dollar
genuinely genuinely helps so for example
right now i'm standing because i was
able to afford a standing desk
sounds like a minor treat but it's a
major one for me
it also helps me do this full time
as for chris langan someone mentioned
chris langan
i am studying chris langan's work he has
a cognitive
theoretic model of the universe i have
some of his papers
right here going through that
meticulously that will take about
two or three more weeks
okay as for eric weinstein yes i will be
talking to eric weinstein in a
about a month or two months when i've
had a chance to go through his
theory of everything that's provided
that he's able to at that point
again thank you all so much
you